and my expert medical opinion
you gotta get standing this well you're
an orthodontist so if I need braces I'll
ask your expert medical opinion without
recommend a back brace no I don't wanna
back up that's how the prescriptions
already out please yeah you're convinced
[Music]
I know you're not going to the office
right now
she says we grab a hard drive and answer
a few emails if you keep working hundred
hour weeks like this you're gonna flame
out or throw your back on my way back
into the office as we speak
I'll get it done right away I seem to
remember you working all the time and
you had your residency yeah Metin are
defined in time
so is this I just gotta put my time pay
my dues enough to see you and on your it
twice as where does anyone else there
yeah because I'm the only analyst about
MBA spent half my time just fixing my
own mistakes it's not putting yourself
down you're the only one there without
an MBA cuz you're the only one who
doesn't need one you stay past midnight
taking over we don't want you fall
asleep behind the wheel okay okay almost
done
[Music]
like their bed okay
don't stay up too late working all right
I'm almost done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and just wanted to shout out and hard
work and wrapping up the Millstone the
tires count well do you want to marry
him or not in theory you know a few
years from now and my career has worked
out and I'm worth millions of dollars
so retirement basically I love him the
problem we haven't even talked about it
people typically don't talk about
engagement it's a surprise ring is a
surprise the marriage you talk about
okay yeah I'll be home in two hours
three tops okay I promise before
breakfast dinner will be in the fridge
okay thank you I love you you said you
weren't gonna be working hundred hour
weeks once millstone was over no stone
is done and it's 1:00 a.m. so was a
fluke okay Paul is out sick and I had to
cover something [ __ ] I still barely see
you and when I do you're distracted and
a nervous wreck unless you're inbox zero
you are seeking out work for no reason
and seeing you miserable is making me
miserable oh you liked it better when I
was sitting at home unemployed or I was
just spending my time surfing LinkedIn
and stress cleaning the fridge is that
the me that you like why does it have to
be one or the other because half of the
reason I have this job is my work ethic
I'm not as smart as these people okay I
have to work harder got to stop [ __ ]
on yourself all the time
why do you do that
no I don't I wish I did but I don't I'm
gonna bet oh my my daughter got it for
ya it's bookie anyway I wanted to talk
to you about marshalled Spencer leaving
you heard he's leaving right now right
yeah well it means that we're gonna have
an associate position open and depending
on how you handle Tanaka in the next
couple of weeks just wanted to see if
you're interested oh absolutely
right Eleni Charny
and if we feel like a joint Halloween
anniversary party I would do everything
okay I would make the invites I'd bias
couples costumes I'll do the decoration
you have to promise me you're gonna cut
back okay the work emails no work emails
did you like your shoulder kiss so that
you felt it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful
with another round of antibiotics you
probably ready for a replacement
hey hope to not go oh good why did you
hear anything no Megan
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are you doing it I just
had to answer some emails okay well
we've just came here to talk sure
[Applause]
[Music]
and is it okay not okay
and
[Music]
won't turn it on I'm sorry about
dropping your laptop the coming out
mother's overshadow the fact that I just
found you working in secret in the shed
I went to the shed I answered a couple
of emails that would have taken me five
minutes I have to hide everything from
check that you can make me feel guilty
do I need to check with you now to do
that just shows me that you don't
actually care about changing you don't
think this is a problem
you're just trying to get you're not a
problem I'm cutting it back for you
dear friends outside wondering where you
are is this really the kind of person
you want to be an email junkie Gmail
don't not outside doing crack okay you
don't even treat me like an actor so I'm
trying to do is to get you to home I did
I was working you caught me how long you
been a relish in this victory
why would I relish in this why I'm not
trying to score points with you and I'm
trying to help him you want to help me
give me space and let me do my job
I don't need you to swoop in here with
your engagement
what are you saying you found the ring
mm-hmm I didn't use anything found it
six weeks ago we've never even talked
about getting married I am
[Music]
I returned it two weeks
what
why would you do that
because I didn't think he'd say yes and
I also didn't know if I wanted you to
anymore
then why are we having a Halloween party
I was trying not to have this
conversation so close for our
anniversary
you've just been phoning it in for a few
weeks and you think I'm the one who lies
I need you to get out of here please and
outside of you you need to see somebody
about this okay like a professional okay
thank you
because I've been trying it okay that's
fine please leave
get out Derek
[Music]
just a second
hi sorry I live next door
can you give me a minute yeah sorry to
bother you we can hear your music not
right now okay okay
did you turn it Harris okay yes yeah
okay I have a big test
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]